the pullout of US troops from Syria has
America's allies bracing for more
conflict President Trump spoke to
Turkey's president on the phone
yesterday and warned him not to mistreat
members of the Kurdish community who are
fighting Isis alongside the United
States Turkey accuses some Kurdish
groups of terrorism Charlie d'Agata
filed this report from inside Syria on
the front lines of the war against Isis
good morning there's been an increase in
the intensity of the battle against Isis
holdouts as Syrian democratic forces
make the most of US military support
while the troops are still here now
there are roughly 2000 US forces they've
been a vital part of this fight against
Isis along with Kurdish led fighters on
the ground they not only provide tactics
weaponry and equipment but crucially
they're directing airstrikes against
Isis targets and we witnessed that for
ourselves aboard the USS Stennis just
last week in the Persian Gulf wave after
wave of f-18 fighters headed here
bombing raids against Isis targets in
Iraq and Syria now while that
partnership between US forces and
Kurdish fighters has proven to be
successful it's angered neighboring
Turkey which considers elements within
those Kurdish led forces terrorists that
they've been at odds with for decades
now Kurds here not only concerned that
the withdrawal of US troops could enable
an Isis come back but the Turkish back
forces will go on the attack the moment
the last American soldier leaves now for
the moment anyway SDF commanders on the
ground here tell us they've seen no
significant drawdown in fact it's more
like a hurry-up offense as they try to
take back as much Isis territory as they
can while US troops are still here for
CBS this morning Charlie d'Agata in
northern Syria